>> DAVID: Okay, orientation is good. "Orientation
about new," up. Alright, so we've just launched
about half an hour ago the ability to now
export a single wave. I'll talk about--Soren
will talk about how to export more waves later
on. But this feature we just launched to now
let you to actually get your waves now in
a ZIP file format with all your attachments
or as HTML with no attachments whatsoever.
It's really only targeted for people who only
have a few waves they want to keep and just
archived. I'll show you now. It's not super,
super fast. Is this one? Yup, so I can go
export. I can go ZIP bundle. I can get attachments
if I wanted to but there's no attachment to
this. What--it actually takes about 30 seconds
to admit it because what it does is it renders
the content on a server, produces--and the
PDF and let you download it so that the whole
process essentially runs the browser on the
server. So if someone here can come up with
a better way in making this faster we take
all recommendations. And by the way, this
was done by a Google person who donated their
time to do this and thanks, thanks to him
for doing that. Okay, so now, I think I've
downloaded this somewhere. Wave three. I can
open it and I get a PDF so which looks like
this, so you get your content back. All right.
So that's announcement number one.
>> Can you demonstrate it one more time?
>> DAVID: Okay. Let me just give you an example
with an attachment. Let me find a wave with
an attachment and I'll let you explore with
that. So, we find one with an attachment.
You know what, I'm just going to upload an
attachment for the sake of doing it. And that's
the way I want, downloads. Let's do this.
Now I click, done, so now I can now go export,
include attachments. So, you can actually
now download the attachment. The attachments
will be in a separate folder that you can
get where the attachments at. Now, it's--it's
unfortunate that there is one thing we have
to be careful of. You--there you go--here's
your files and you get your file back. Yeah,
well, it's a screenshot of Facebook but the
important thing is that if you have an image
you will not be able to get your original
image back because we actually compress images
when we store on the server site. But if ever
you get by default you get the file back.
We want to give you the original image back
but we can't because for space reasons we
already actually chop, trim the images before
we store it so you'll never get to get the
same image back. So just be aware of that.
But if you have lots of ways, I think Soren
have
the answer for you. Cool.
>> SOREN: Okay. So, it's not--so, yeah, we
promised that we would make it possible to
import waves through your Wave in a Box instance.
And so, we are at work here, in particular,
Christian has been--has written some code
to make--through the Data API that you can
pragmatically slip up your waves. So, what
you can do right now with the Data API is
that you can--so you can pragmatically come
in by OAuth and authenticate if you--so you
can have--so the idea is that we want to make
it possible for you to add codes to Wave in
a Box so they can dial them up out at Data
API on the production--the Google Wave production
system and read out your waves. And that so
the Data API has OAuth authentication so that
if you give your credentials to your Wave
in a Box instance and the code you write for
that, then it can dial up and do a fetch wavelet.
First of all, it can use the search options
on the Data API to find the relevant wave.
So you can search for inbox and it can see
all the wavelets--waves. Then, you can do
a fetch wavelet request to read out the wave
including the attachments in there. The problem
with the current Data API is that it gives
you a certain text representation of the contents
of a wavelet. But what we are adding this
week--so we hope to get it out within the
next 48 hours so that when we get to the hacking
on Thursday and Friday that this option is
there and is live. So, anyone who's game can
start coding up for as something to pullout
the waves and put them into Wave in a Box.
And what we have--so what we're adding is
an option to--an optional argument to the
fetch wavelet's method. We can ask to have
them to get the row of deltas in there out
so that they'll come out. And so we still
are trying to get the binary format right
but it's--it would be a faithful binary representation
of the deltas and the operations in there
so that you can then stick them into the wave
store in the Wave in a Box and you'll get
the wave with the--with all the--with the
entire--a faithful copy of the wave with the
history. So, we're getting there. I think
that should make a--so that--yesterday, there
were some request about getting it out in
an HTML format so you can better process the
contents. This should be the most faithful
exporter that is possible to give you. So,
I think--yes, I had commented also--PDF and
HTML exports is now live as David showed you.
This, if all goes well, we'll get the Data
API export option out this week. And then
the third thing we--Christian didn't promise
to make waves available in docs. So that's
our export story. Questions?
>> Yeah. No, sorry. I don't have questions.
e request about getting it out in an HTML
format so you can better process the contents.
This should be the most faithful exporter
that is possible to give you. So, I think--yes,
I had commented also--PDF and HTML exports
is now live as David showed you. This, if
all goes well, we'll get the Data API export
option out thi